how did you reach out to these
individuals did you send them an email
and what was your pitch quote unquote
like was it a short email or was it a
long one it was really simple you know I
had some people that open doorways a
couple really instrumental people that
just said he that knew them already and
said would you you know consider
interviewing with this with rana prince
in this film but it really when I
personally got involved and I said to
people would you be interested in
interviewing in sacred journey of the
heart everyone said sure and they didn't
have a whole lot more questions
sometimes they said what's it about but
here's the the key about this that I
know because one of my love's is
numerology I love numerology for me it
explains the world not from that the
head but there's a vibrational energy of
numbers that I get and sacred journey of
the heart equals 111 111 and just by
Pythagorean numerology a is morn bees
too and so I really believe that there's
a vibrational energy around this sacred
journey of the heart that would bring
people towards it and say there there's
a balance there's a balance beyond
polarity and duality into something new
that's being created a convergence or
confluence but I talked about in the
film so that's my personal opinion
you